hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
simplify complex genetic diseases by
quantifying structural and copy number
variants my name is mark lynch and i'm
of genomic vision
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by genomic vision to
learn more visit genomicvision.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you
may have during the presentation to do
so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
now like to welcome our speaker for
today mario avarello
who's a product manager here at genomic
vision
mario you may begin your presentation
thank you mark for the ninth
presentation and welcome to you all
to the second session of this genomic
vision
uh summer webinar program my name is
mario morello and i'm
product manager here at genomic vision
today i'm gonna walk you into the
the molecular combing for precise
detection
and quantification of genomic
rearrangement as in a single dna
molecule resolution i will introduce to
you
the application of our characteristic
genomic morse codes
to level specific dna regions that are
depicted by our fiber vision
and analyzed automatically by our fiber
studio software
the use of gmc such as a molecular
marker for understanding
of complex genomic rearrangements such
as expansion
shortening and other complex
modification
in addition we can use gmc
to actually understand the genomic
variability
such as mosses and it's easy to
quantify to the power of our technology
at single dna molecule resolution
i just want to remember that this is the
second
session of our summer webinar program
uh so in the past you actually learn
what are the normal uh procedure
generically of our molecular combing
and what are the different steps so you
have some insights
about our gmc about our
cancer biology methods and for genetic
and rare diseases
and also something for the geneticity
today
we are going to focus in these uh to
the cases of the use of molecular
combing and our gmc
for understanding the genomic
rearrangement
in specific cases so in specific
genetic diseases and
the next summer webinar
in the the next session we're actually
looking forward to have you and walk you
through the cancer biology and how to
understand
the mechanism of cancer and normal cells
while on july 1st it is going to be the
introduction
for the gen editing and how to use
molecular combing to qualify and
quantify gene editing events
but let's start for this session well we
actually
will go through the the use of molecular
combing
gmc and the the entire platform
to understand uh the some of the
diseases the first one is fshd
it's a rare disease that and our gmc
enabled the detection of repeat
contractions
to facilitate the diagnosis of
physicists for for patients while in the
second
case we actually use the gmc to see
the repeated expansions and quantify
these expansions
in a specific patient's suffering of a
disease called fame three
before starting i would like to give you
an overview
about our genomic morse codes
so the genomic morse code is actually a
molecular marker
to hybridize probe
and visualize specific sequences of the
dna
and then physically we can actually see
what are
the genomic rearrangements of the
genomic variability that the patient
is suffering off so in this case you can
see that there are different sequences
so we are able to see repeats we are
able to distinguish distances between
two different probes or to measure the
length
and all of this is possible because we
create an exclusive pattern of color
in the first exam example you see
that there is the sequence of interest
they think grey with the specific sides
of the supposed deletion it's in yellow
so in this case we actually design
probes
uh that are blue red and green
and then when there is addition we
actually see
that the red is getting shorter in the
gen 2 in this case there is an
amplification so this is the case of the
copy number variation
and now the red tract is actually bigger
and in case of inversion we can see
the flip between the colors and leads in
the wild type it's
blue long blue green and
red and short blue and in the version
you can see that it's
long blue red and green this time
and then again the short blue so these
are just few examples of the use of our
genomic morse codes to
investigate what are these genomic
rearrangements
in a patient or in a specific disease
so but then we can actually see more
complex
and connected with genomic variability
such as moses
this method is actually bring genomic
vision
to to be to have a strength to have be
very powerful into the markets because
we actually can see the direct fibers so
we have a dark visualization
of the dna itself or our specific locus
we can do the direct detection
of the the locus itself uh
without any technical bias because we
take the dna we extract it
we can't so we stretch on a specific
cover sleep
and then without using any enzymes
we basically probe that specific
sequence
that can be uh any kind of sequence
even g c reach regions or repetitive
regions
or large variants that are more than one
megabase
so this is what the strength of the use
of single dna
molecules and our gmc
together
but let's start specifically at the
summit of the example and
we will focus on the first one that is
indeed
the fshd and how gmc is able
to detect the rapid contraction
that leads to the disease onset
so fshd is actually the fascicolous
couple of humeral dystrophy
is a kind of muscular dystrophy and this
is due
to the contraction on a specific
sequence there's
the chromosome 4q35
there are actually two type of disease
called indeed
fshd1 and fhp2
the two diseases are actually onsets
is due to different rearrangements uh
the
fshd1 is due to a contraction
of the rapid expansion while the fst2
is due to mutation and emit genetics
genes
so with genomic vision we actually focus
on the fshd1 so then
on the repeat contractions on a specific
sequence that is called the force before
in order to understand
how many uh r units of
these uh before the four are actually
contracted in in the disease in the
patients
so this the 404 is actually
present also in the chromosome 4
specifically at the 10
q26 and both either in the chromosome 4
or the chromosome
10 in the hablo type a and b
but for the disease uh the onset of the
disease
it's the shortening is happening only on
the chromosome 4 q35 so
the chromosome 4q upload type a
the use of genomic vision technology
with the
gmc in a single dna molecule resolution
it's very powerful
because bring some strength uh compared
to the classical methods that is in this
southern bonds
so for us uh fshd
test is actually one short experiment so
in one coverslip the
kind of information that can bring to
the
to helping the physician for a diagnosis
it's
actually huge and this will not require
any enzymatic manipulation
so we just as i mentioned before calm
the dna and then prop the sequence
so there is no need to use a
restriction enzymes to amplify the
signal
for the d404 and then used to
classify whether it's in the four cubes
and q
whether it's a or b this would be a
unique solution and indeed
by probing we can see that the force
before
directly we can see in the same
experiment whether it's chromosome 4
or chromosome 10 whether it's the
archotype a or b we can also see
the other rearrangements like the p13e11
and then this will bring to
identification
of further or more complex modifications
such as multi-themes complex
rearrangements
and even satellite region rearrangement
some of these are
very complicated to identify or nearly
impossible with southern blots
and the last is that we have
developed a fiber studio software indeed
to standardize the analysis
if we look at the workflow that is
needed to perform our sht
test these are the material that we need
so in the first we have the our
extraction kit that's called fiber prep
is an exclusive kit that use the
the extraction via plug preparation in
order to preserve
the integrity of the dna and the fibers
after combing can go up to uh one
megabase
uh then the dna is actually stretched or
calmed
on our specific cover sleeves that are
chemically treated in order that only
the dna ends will bind the surface of
the cover sleeve
and our specific machine called
fibercom is actually the one that's
gonna make the strength
to calm the dna fiber
on the coverslip then we use our fshsp
probes
uh to hybridize the fshd
signals for the chromosome 4 and then
d4c4
and our automated scanner called
fibervision
actually depicts the entire color scheme
by taking 25 by 25 picture
stitching together in order to
digitalize the cover slip
from a physical one to a digital one and
later that our firebase studio software
will detect and maybe
semi-automatic analysis to identify and
quantify
the defaults for shortening and
the complex arrangements that are
happening on it
so looking carefully out of how
this gmc are designed uh we can actually
see here that
indeed we designed uh probes for the
chromosome 4
and the chromosome 10 so we actually
decided to take
uh upstream that the force before and
indeed we created the powder of color
then
in this case is red green magenta blue
for the chromosome 4
and then we hybridize the green
trucks before the d404 and at the end
there is a small tract for the
chromosome for the upper type a
when it's red and b when it's blue
and at very ends we have the the
beginning of the telomere
in red while for the chromosome 10 we
use our different codes
at the very beginning indeed we have
blue
magenta blue is actually the sign
for the chromosome 10 and then again we
have the deposit 4
in green hypotype a and b in red
blue and the telomere signal in red
and and then is how it looked like
for in the real picture so
in this case our scientist has done a
study
using more than thousand patients uh
that
were dubious patients from uh analysis
previously done by thousand blocks in
this case we
rerun the analysis again by molecular
combing
and the sshd probes uh
from gmc so here as you can see
this is a real picture of uh of
combing experiments and we have that red
green magenta blue is the chromosome 4
and blue magenta blue is the chromosome
10. so you can already see the two
before the four and what is
actually the length that they'll be
speaking about and at the end you see
the red dots to distinguish the
product a while below you have the blue
dots
for the hypothy b and
the red structure at the end actually
will tell us that this is an intact
signal
so uh by using this methodology
actually uh our scientists were able
to classify 61 of those
out of those thousand patients as non
uh 42 contracted patients
while 32 having the contraction
so this is already a good refine of the
previous
technologies done by southern blots just
using our gmc in addition
as i mentioned before it is possible to
distinguish
for more complex rearrangements such as
a proximal deletion
where you actually see that the blue
probe is missing
or assist the application where there is
actually a dash between the green and
red
and in general we also looked at a more
complex rearrangement such as mosaicism
and all of these patients they actually
are about to be eight percent
so in addition to understand precisely
and refine
the analysis done by southern blots
uh by using our molecular combing we can
actually
see for the first time and make all
these studies to understand what is the
correlation
of the deforester for contraction with
the satellite region
indeed uh we have been measuring
the chromosome 4 chromosome 10 and the
qa the distance from the 4z4 to the
beginning of the telomere
and what we saw roughly is like that
there is no
much difference in the length between
these two subtheramic regions
but then we look carefully at the
subtheramic
regions in the patients having a
different length of 34c4
and what we actually see that there is
an increased distance
uh between the theramatic regions in the
44
repeat contracted patients so in the
compared to
healthy individuals of course so this is
actually the power again of our gnc
that will bring all full insights on
what might happen
and we have the physicians to have a
better review
to make a better diagnosis for our
patients
and indeed all of this application
has been used to from the physicians
to make the diagnosis of the patients
between fsh321
and probably fshd t2 patients in this
we have for example these four patients
in the first two
we actually saw that there is a before
before
contraction and specifically the first
one has
five units before the four and in
addition there is a deletion of
the p13e11 uh
while the second one has the deletion of
the k13 e11 region
together with three units of the d4c4
so clearly these two patients were
diagnosed of
us of fshd1 patients but
if we look at the other two patients
these again are coming from
adobe southern blots analysis we
actually found that those patients had
12 repetitive
units of before the 4 and there was
a deletion in one of them of the piece
of team so
these two patients has been classified
as
not fshd1 and most probably
those belong to fshd2 so in this case
again the molecular combing and gmc
analysis
is a great technology to
refine and give a precise analysis
and help physician to classify better
patients for
the fshd1 or the fshd2
and with this we are at the end of this
first part of this session
where we i actually introduce you uh the
molecular combing technology and the use
of
single dna molecule what is the strength
uh of this molecule with gmc for
fssd1 uh diagnosis in a unique
and robust solution indeed i show you
that
uh above a thousand patients that has
been analyzed
uh 32 percent are actually true
especially
one patient while by southern blotting
this was still
a dubious result and among of these
eight percent also had more complex
genomic variability such as processes
assist application
and then molecular combing has brought
also insights
that are not possible to quantify with
other technologies
such as there's a paramedic region and
regarding
this we actually saw that between the
four q and then q the subthalamic
regions
are highly prone to recombine and evolve
independently
so these actually open up to further
discussion that would
need more research and have scientists
and physicians to make a better
diagnosis
for the fshd1 patient
in the second part of the webinar i will
actually introduce you
to the opposite case where we have our
repeat
expansions uh between two
intro in this case uh we again use
patient samples from a specific disease
that is called same three
frame three is actually familiar adult
mycolonic epilepsy the type 3 indeeds
from this disease there are different
kinds of subtypes from one to six
according what is the specific biomarker
that is actually
bringing to the onset of the disease due
to some modification
in this case for frame 3 is actually
9.3 megabase long and this is occurring
on the chromosome 5p
and specifically is within a gene that's
called mark six
between two action we have action one
and x and
two and then we have these intronic
parts where
and in red you can see the actual site
where
the repeat insertion can happen
indeed from different studies
what has been looked by the scientists
is the
identification of the causes from
fm3 onsets so scientists
have been using many of the sequencing
technologies but all
were unable to give an outcome
so at this case they reside they decide
to use the rp pcr
so and this because indeed you can see
that
in a normal case uh there are the two in
the two action
xn1 and xm2 and there is already
a repeated expansion between the two
that goes from nine to
twenty but in the pathological condition
this expansion is actually even extended
more
so and by the nature of this extension
due to the factors
uh repeated sequences they did the
sequencing technology
uh was not giving a precise outcome
by rppcr indeed the scientists have seen
that rapid expansion is composed by ttta
or ttdca
into the march 6 region
so subsequently once the scientists
had known what is causing the onset of
the disease
they decided to characterize the disease
and indeed
and they focus on the use of long-range
sequencing where they could actually see
within different patients what are the
repeat expansions between
unhealthy and unhealthy
patients but again there was some
limitation on it
due to the fact that these are repeated
sequences
and indeed you can see from the map
where in yellow
uh within different patients are the
the intronic sequences uh that are
normally present
and in red there is the expansions but
that cannot be measured precisely
because
there is some gap of the sequencing
between
all these expansions
so in this case the sequencing could not
give
a precise overview of the onsets
of the disease
so at that point we decided to focus
with calming and help
physician in uh make their diagnosis for
the patients
and again we use the strength of single
molecule
uh fibers and our gmc to design
probes uh for the two intranet for the
two
accents in blue and in green and the
intron and yellow
and when there is the repeat expansion
we actually have the expansion in red
so here you can see clearly from the
example where is a wild type
and a pathological condition in a real
combing
and this has been analyzing the
different patients where they
actually could see what is the the onset
of the disease on these patients the
risk to have the disease
on these patients so again
the sensory analysis of single dna
molecules with molecular combing show
that the
expansions can range from 3.3 kb
up to 14 kb and this is
the strength of our gnc and the user
molecular company together
in addition to have a precise
measurements
of the repeat expansions that are
causing
disease again we could look at
complex genomic variability that are
happening
within the patients and leads to have
somatic moses
so in this case you can see in real
pictures what are the
kind of different uh genomic variability
that we had
within the patients for example having
the rigid expansions
at the ends of the xn2 or where is a
combination within the accents
and then we can precisely measure and
quantify
these rearrangements within the same
cover sleep
uh between the different uh
patients so this brought us to
actually have that the micro
rearrangements can represent the ten
percent
of the allele all our cover slip and
this is the strength
of our resolution to having with
by molecular combing the precise
measurement
and also precise quantification of
complex rearrangements that
can happen in a specific disease or a
specific case
and by this we are at the end of the
second session so i will just give you
the summary
where we spoke about molecular combing
technology and how
can we use in our complementary methods
with sequencing so the single dna
molecule analysis
can be used in clinical research indeed
to computate
without any bias the results are
generated by sequencing or other
technologies
and these are actually led to have a
precise measurement of the number of
extension
in a specific case that was uh frame
three
and lead the physician to understand the
onset
of the disease and we could
actually identify also what are the
complex rearrangements that are
happening into these patients
uh intra and inter samples
and again molecular combat gives a full
detail of a patient
suffering of a disease and the
possibility to have
most assessment that is not too that
easy to
actually see with other methods
by this we are at the end of this
session
of this gb summer webinar program
i would like to remind you that on june
24th it's gonna be the next session
that will focus on cancer biology and
what are
actually the kinetics that bring
specifically to the cancer development
rather than normal diseases
and by this i would like to
thank you all for your attention and i
will be happy to take
questions thank you so much
thank you mario for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you would like us
to answer please type
type it now in the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so with that mario we'll get started
with the
first question that is coming in
so the first question relates to fshd
and it is what is the genome requirement
per cover slip for fshd
high mark and high all presenters to
this
um webinar so just to answer the
questions
we actually seen that on a cover sleep
we have something about a hundred
equivalent per genome so we
always start with about 5 ml of
blood that this will allow us to have
this
quantity so by using 500 ml of blood
we'll have per cover sleep 100
equivalent to a genome
and at the end we actually looking
detecting and making analysis uh for
70 intact signals uh for the 4q
a and the 10qa and these are already
enough
to have statistical significant uh
significant results
great thanks mario the next question
also relates to the
fshd clinical assay can the fshd
clinical ibd assay
be used with blood cells or saliva
uh yeah thank you for the question and
really interesting uh
yet can be used with blood cells at the
moment we don't use
saliva we usually ask to collect
fresh samples coming either from the
blood or from the tissue
from the patient
perfect thank you um another question
that came in um other than detecting
mutations
can this method be used to view
certain alleles in chromosomes to detect
certain genetic diseases such as color
blindness or
hemophilia
uh that's really good question indeed
because uh using our uh characteristic
gmc we actually probed the dna
so at this point we actually have a
single dna molecule that are linear
so we normally design probes for
the sequence of interest that can be
a native sequence or sequence that
brings to disease
or sequence that has some mutation but
uh theoretically we just probe dna so
this brings us to
it detects any kind of sequence on the
on the genome okay
perfect um another question that
came in how do you avoid the expansions
and staining of the non-coding regions
i.e introns
uh we actually uh
avoid the expansions because we don't
use any enzyme
so this is just pure calms
dna it's pure dna that is stretched on a
cover sleeve
and when it's fixed then we go for
hybridization
so there is no modification by using
enzyme
so and in this way we can actually
detect
intronic sequences without uh having any
modification of
i it okay um
another question here in
for fame three um can
real-time pcr be used
for the same type of detection and how
does combing
compare to real-time pcr
uh the we actually they can be used
side-by-sides
in our opinion in order to enrich the
analysis
uh in using together uh the
at the time the paper has been done
using a different kind of
sequencing or different even kind of a
assays
uh to identify the
the intronic sequence first and then to
actually understand
how many repeats so what is the length
and as i mentioned before the the
very successful one was using the
rp pcr and then the combing these were
the two
techniques that uh the the our
scientists our collaborator has used
actually to to have a clear result
of what are the modifications of the
intronic sequences
and precisely measure the expansions and
whether they are
there are micro rearrangements
okay perfect thank you
um another few questions coming in mario
um
one relates to the blood the blood being
the input for some of the assays with
molecular combing
um is the is the application of
molecular combing
uh incompatible with any type of
stabilizer
or any anti-coagulant of the blood tubes
that the blood is collected in
that you know of well that
that's very interesting question and so
far
actually we uh haven't had any problem
or any effect or said effect uh with
stabilizer
because actually there is a unique way
to process the blood
from the very beginning so and this
unique way is actually to start from the
blood and immediately
as soon as possible go to the
generation of black and then the dna
actually in the plug it's pretty stable
and can
be kept for even longer than an year
so just following this process basically
we don't need to it basically makes the
the the technique compatible with the
odd theater
stabilizer or yeah the other method to
process blood
okay thanks so we have one last question
that's here in the
question field some of the images
have some background fluorescence on
them
and the questioner is asking would that
interfere with the result
yeah that's true that's true and uh the
users of probes
actually and our specific cover sleeves
that are
actually would like to remind us that
have uh uh
they are coded chemically in order to
allow the
dna ants to bind it
actually retain sometimes probes so this
might increase a bit the background
but actually we have developed the
fiber studio software that allow us to
have
a precise detection of the signal and
then
we usually design the gmc in order
to have any avoidance
to avoid any problem or any bias coming
from the background so
each probe each segment that you see has
a specific
length and we know so and putting
together
the uh detection of the software and the
length
of each segment each color we
actually are sure that there is no bias
introduced by the background itself
understood and we have time for one more
question that's just coming in
um since this method is very new and
really unique
how compatible is this for everyday
experimental
use
yeah that's a good question uh it's uh
this
this is a really new method as you
mentioned and
we are improving our technology and we
are
always changing our software in order
that will become uh more automated
and more precise for the detection so
this brings us
to to have a really high stroke boots
and that can be used uh
in every day in lab and also our
machines
as mentioned before for example the
fiber vision the automated scanner
can actually host up to 160 samples
and it takes about 160 minutes for
for each coverslip so at the end uh
it's actually a quite good method that
can be used
for every day in lab
thanks mario so we don't have any other
questions at this time in the box mario
do you have any final comments for our
audience today
uh thank you mark uh well no i don't
have any other comments i will just to
uh thank you all for their attention
and i would like to
bring again what is the strength of the
use of molecular combing to identify
specific sequences on the dna that can
bring to
that can be mutated can bring to some
diseases
and with this i'd like to thank you all
for your attention
and i will look forward to meet you all
at the next session
on july 24th where we'll actually focus
on more on cancer biology and the tools
that we use to understand
the mechanistic role of
cancer of the revocation in cancer and
how can be used
for the the drug screening
excellent thank you again mario for your
time today and your important work here
that you've presented
we'd also like to thank lab roots for
facilitating today's educational webcast
before we go i'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions was very
interactive
for any questions that we did not have
time to get to today
um or for any that are submitted during
the on-demand
period of the webinar these will be
addressed via mario
through the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage that you share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
and we look forward to seeing you at
part three of our webinar series on june
24th
improved quantitative understanding of
oncological replication kinetics
using molecular coming until then
thank you and goodbye